alien was directed by Ridley Scott and
started a humongous franchise that is
still being continued today in fact very
soon alien covenant is coming out and
that's why I'm going to be reviewing
every single alien movie all four of the
originals as well has Haley and vs.
predator one and two this is gonna be a
lot of fun for at least a few of these
movies it'll be fun
I don't have to tell you guys that alien
is a revolutionary movie from a
special-effects standpoint from a
concept standpoint this movie let us
know that so much could be done on film
and it did it so successfully that it
still works today just as well as it did
in 1979 even though I wasn't alive I'm
assuming because a lot of people liked
it when it came out and a lot of people
still liked it so alien is about the
crew of the ship Nostromo who are awoken
from hypersleep to investigate a
distress signal on a planet when they
get to this planet a very strange entity
attaches itself to one of their crew and
eventually gives birth to a gigantic
alien creature that begins to take them
all out one by one I didn't see alien as
a child I saw it when I was about 15 or
16 for the first time and I saw the
director's cut first and I was blown
away by this movie I showed it to all my
friends who had never seen it instantly
I wanted everyone to experience this
film and I'm glad that I didn't see it
too young and was able to at least
appreciate certain things in this movie
namely HR Giger's very sexually
disturbing imagery that's very prevalent
in this movie the design of the alien
creature itself the way the facehugger
attaches itself to you and then
impregnates you there's a deep
psychologically disturbing sexual
violation feel to just about everything
in this movie from the way the creatures
give birth to the way they kill you how
the xenomorph mouth opens up and another
mouth comes out it all just feels as if
it is reaching some very gross hidden
psychologically disturbing aspect that
we are all very afraid of Ridley Scott's
direction and the editing of his
sequences is so suspenseful it really
reaches inside of you
makes you feel as if you are on this
ship the set design is immaculate this
is still one of the coolest looking
movie ships of all time the inside of
this thing feels so dirty and lived in
it feels like a real environment there's
nothing glassy or clean to it it all
feels like something tangible you could
reach into the screen and become a part
of and the crew itself is also very well
realized you get the sense of how
everyone works together you have ash who
is the science officer you have Parker
and Brett who are the mechanics you have
Dallas the captain it's easy to
understand how the ship operates
everything makes sense it's not just a
really fun science fiction movie that
has an alien monster that's really
awesome you can tell that Ridley Scott
and the writers and the production crew
and everyone was just trying to make a
world that felt like it could work it
wasn't just about this creature or
special effects this was a real lived-in
universe even though you're seeing such
a small little part of it which is
something else about this film that I
love I absolutely adore contained
suspense horror and there are a lot of
films that have since taken the alien
vibes and built off of that there's a
very very unknown anime film called Lily
cats that is essentially a complete
ripoff of this movie I've talked about
it on my japanimation era retro rewind
video the movie event horizon from Paul
WS Anderson definitely has a very
similar feel lots of films have apes
this movie for many years and none of
them have ever lived up to it
something else that alien did
masterfully that's actually really
difficult to do is not have a clear-cut
protagonist for quite some time you
don't really understand who the lead of
the movie is until Sigourney Weaver as
Ripley steps up about halfway through
until then it's really just the crew
itself is the protagonist the team you
feel like you're there with them you
feel like you are absolutely in this
moment for a while you think it might be
Tom Skerritt as Dallas the captain but
eventually you learn that no that's not
really the case either Ripley is the one
who has to stand up and take control of
the situation and watching that
character blossom in this movie - what
she eventually becomes in the next few
films is so much fun to see since I've
seen all of them and I know how it all
goes
I love
watching Ripley start as the one who is
very clear-cut
she's like no we cannot let these people
back on the ship
it's a quarantine situation they could
infect all of us she's the only one
who's following procedure and as the
rest of the movie goes along she's still
the only character who maintains a clear
head throughout every single situation
even Dallas the captain is like let us
in and that's against protocol and
Ripley's like no I can't do that she's
the strongest character in this movie
she's the one who knows how to follow
protocol and she gets shit done and you
know if you haven't seen alien I'm gonna
get into a few spoilers I'm assuming
most of you have seen this incredible
classic film if you haven't come on man
like really I'm gonna get into some
spoilers here ash let's talk about Ian's
home as ash who eventually reveals
himself to be an Android I loved
watching the film knowing that he is one
because there are so many cutaways to
him with looks that could on first
viewing be normal they work for the
situation but then on second viewing
you're realizing he's analyzing the
situation he's trying to figure out how
can he get this specimen back to earth
it's really brilliant storytelling so
let's talk about the alien creature
itself the xenomorph first off the chest
burster scene is iconic obviously I'm
sure most of you know this but the
actors were actually unaware of what was
going to happen and so when that chest
burster comes out of John Hurt who by
the way rest in peace fantastic actor
sorely missed they didn't know that was
going to happen so their reaction when
that thing go it's totally genuine it's
so great to watch that knowing that but
the xenomorph creature itself to this
day is probably my favorite design for
any alien in film which is kind of sad I
mean this movie came out in 1979 and
we've had so many different alien films
ever since then and nothing has topped
this this thing is just so fucking cool
and terrifying it works so well in this
movie and the sense of horror whenever
it's around is so well utilized by Scott
because he chooses to go the Jaws route
and not show it too often in fact
it's really not in the movie that much
you just get this sense of incredible
paranoia whatever it's nearby or
whenever it's not nearby because he
never lets you out there's rarely a
sequence or a scene or a moment that
lets you breathe for a second like for
instance after brett is taken up into
the air shaft and Parker and Ripley come
in and the Bloods falling down it
instantly cuts to a close-up of Parker
and he just he's like it doesn't let you
out it never gives you that brief moment
between sequences this film keeps you in
its grasp from opening frame to the
final one now out of the two cuts that
are prevalent the theatrical and the
director's cut I prefer the director's
cut Ridley Scott actually made a
director's cut that I feel is better
than the original he's pretty good at
that actually he likes to tinker with
his movies and somehow he's able to do
it without pissing off all of his fans
because he understands what should and
shouldn't be in a film even when he's
going in to tinker and more what I love
about the director's cut is the obvious
additional scene that has Ripley find
Dallas and Brett and their cocoon bodies
and he's like and she you know
flamethrowers them really really awesome
scene and it also explains where they
were not that it needs explaining it's
kind of cool to not know where the
bodies are it leaves it more ambiguous
makes the creature feel more terrifying
like what did the creature do with these
bodies but I like the fact that I know
and it's not a very long scene and I
love the look of the scene with the
yellow and the orange glow but my
favorites Edition in the director's cut
is just one shot it's the first real
close-up frame of the alien when Brett
is walking and just looking for Jones
the cat and you just see this thing
hanging and there's no big musical
reveal there's no jump scare in fact the
first time I saw it I just kind of went
is that oh shit
and that reaction you don't get that in
monster movies because they always build
up the reveal of the creature to this
big epic moment with music and he turns
around and oh my god and that's how it
wasn't a theatrical exactly like that
but in the director's cut Ridley Scott
is like no let's just have this this
wide shot of it hanging up there it
gives me chills it's my favorite
additional moment in the director's cut
guys I don't have to tell you I adore
this movie it's one of my all-time
favorite films alien is a movie that has
stood the test of time successfully it
has engaging characters it has an
incredible creature it's insanely scary
very suspenseful it's one of Ridley
Scott's best films absolutely without a
doubt alien gets an A+ so guys my alien
series is going to be continuing with
reviews for aliens alien 3 Alien
Resurrection AVP 1 and AVP 2 what I
really want you to look forward to is my
review of alien 3 because I'm gonna be
doing that with my buddy Matt Brando who
has a really cool YouTube channel I've
done videos with him before but he has a
particular feeling for alien 3 and I
have a different feeling for alien 3 and
we both want to present a very in-depth
really well researched review of what
alien 3 could have been what they were
trying to make what we eventually got
the differences between theatrical and
the assembly cuts and we just wanted to
present a very kind respectful debate
look forward to that guys it's going
very soon and of course my other reviews
for the aliens movies leading up to
alien covenant which I really hope is
great and I've already reviewed
Prometheus obviously so guys thank you
very much for watching and if you liked
this you can click right here and get
stuck mine eyes
[Applause]
[Music]